what a great turnout this weekend at the
vegas cares about rare 5k at cornerstone
park in henderson you couldn't beat the
weather or the excitement of the crowd
thanks to the volunteers thanks to the
superheroes who came out encouraging
everyone to keep going all the money
raised goes to the little miss hannah
foundation a non-profit which helps kids
here in town who have medically complex
and rare diseases there's bradley the 25
thousand dollars made at this weekend's
race will provide anywhere from 25 to 50
pieces of medical equipment for children
like quinn
it's helped immensely getting things she
needs we've got helmets through them
bath chairs car seats it's things that
we wouldn't have been able to get
without it
this marked the sixth annual race i was
honored as the mc to kick off the events
pass out the awards this was my fifth
year taking part so thanks so much to
carrie and robert austria and jenny
kershall who do so much for the
wonderful children in our community